pour tout vous êtes vous êtes le seul
voilà et ça c'est une exclu touche pas à
mon poste et qui va animer les trois
prime donc accompagné de quelqu'un on ne
sait pas qui alors eh ben vous allez
donc vous videz ça ouvrez votre chemise
à lydiane on ne sait pas très bien sûr
vraiment sur la peau hâlée vous êtes
vous plaisir
j'aime bien ça alésien wars et mahdia
ses gardes
ah ouais quand même si ses mérites et
non 500 isabelle à l'effraction nous
confirme que ça s'en aille
merci bravo annuel maubert
[Applaudissements]
les séries donc voilà je vous le dis
vous allez tout savoir un écarteur de
bouche à vous allez tous vous retourner
un écarteur de bouche regarder voilà
abba trailer engageant luxe et de la
chance pour vous guident alors que la
paille bon vieux café palais oui c'est
vrai gala alors vous vous mettez alors
grâce évidemment vous avez quand même si
je savais comment ça se mettait un loup
dit jean luc lemoine va essayer de vous
mettre voilà regarder à la poche
allez-y voilaaaâ merci alors vous allez
me retourner s'il vous plaît retournez
vous retournez vous allez allez s'il va
y arriver les balles à fond dedans déjà
et vous devez dire good
vous plaît s'il vous plaît vous à venir
attendez vous allez le faire chacun
votre tour s'il vous plaît calmez vous
on va démarrer avec valérie bénaïm
valérie bella et vous devez dire la
phrase vous devez dire la phrase s'il
vous plaît s'il vous plaît on se calme
vous devez dans la phrase
un chasseur sations sachets sans son
chien un chasseur sachant chasser
sachez choisir attention bel hymne
alésia isabelle mont liban
sa prépa aux exercices nature main mais
si ça prépare c'est que tu refais du
monde a atteint deux ans plus tard
pierre fabre et attention enora malagré
[Rires]
voici la console question votre garage
c'est que vous êtes tout seul à le faire
puisque vous avez mal répondu vous allez
devoir ronnie ferait une chaussure d'une
personne du public
allez venez choisir ben on prenait vite
à la première qui mérite la cheminée le
pied ou la chaussure
ben alors voilà la chaussure la manif
les allez-y vous avez voulu vous lui
enlevez vous l'enlever merci quoi ça
c'est de la belle beauty l'aller 0 tours
et vous est-ce qu'on vous voit pas
retourner vous sait très bien
regarde albanie
[Musique]